okay what's something that can compound
forever that has a huge Tam and I said
Layla if I were to die tomorrow what
business would you start and she was
like I would start a recruiting firm is
there a way that we could combine what
you like and what I like into something
cool for us like the most Hands-On
valuable thing that you can do for a
business is find a players our
competitive mode is that we have more
influence we have tons of people every
single day that are applying for
portfolio positions and then we can
screen them vet them and then because we
know the company and because we're
long-term incentivized we don't just
want to like put a body in a seat we
want to fill it with somebody who
matches the culture and matches the
skill set of the business at this level